literally you rest your like to the
point where like you're hit your hands
are like kind of like shaking almost and
then it just starts and sometimes it
really is freaky and goes really fast
okay I'm gonna take a little home please
still buy my book I swear I'm not a
Satan worshiper okay Stassi mm-hmm
we had to pull out the Ouija board
because you write about the Ouija board
in your book yeah next level basic out
now if you're watching this buy it now
I've never done a Ouija board are you
kidding no like never as a kid never
ever never
well are we like playing it for real
yeah we're getting into it I'm not sure
it will work because come every other
lighting all of the people here all of
the cameras TV studio is not conduced
it's not energy it's not no okay well we
gotta break out the wine two for wine
and Ouija cheers Cheers Barrett's that
hopefully come through okay okay
do you believe only kind of like dick
spirits come through we do yeah just
douchebags like bored ghosts that like
really don't know what's up and they're
just like I don't know what to do so I'm
just gonna go for people like those like
it's never actually who you want to
connect with all right so we just start
by saying is anybody here I mean it's
really not gonna we have to try okay
okay
it's anybody here right now we just want
to talk to you if you're here do you
have hair extensions
[Music]
if you're here do you want wine yes does
anyone want to talk to us all right well
I'm just gonna ask you some questions
okay you want to push it to where we'll
stop seeing Bo get engaged this year
there's gonna take a while to answer all
your friggin questions bro maybe okay
well I don't know when he's gonna
propose but you know it's coming at some
point it could come any time though like
it Rick he could wait I don't know I'm
trying not to be a pusher cuz I tend to
do that okay growth all right so you're
not putting any pressure on it to be
this year yeah but like if he wants to
I'm totally okay with that how much
longer will Stassi do Vanderpump rules
for oh my god I know I'm gonna do the
infinity sign uh-huh as long as the show
goes it'll go on we could be like the
Golden Girls
our husbands are all dead our children
are grown when we're still eating goat
cheese balls it's ER Wow I mean how epic
would that be do you feel like the
action is gonna move away from Sur in
the future I think that if we're gonna
keep going forever it has to because it
has to follow what's really going on in
our lives and and that's just life feel
like it's unfair to expect that like
lalala is still gonna be hosting at Sur
for 20 more years when she's flying on a
private jet every single day like do
they go in there and work at Sur yeah
but it's for a very short amount of time
because they can't handle it there's too
many people right how do you feel about
maybe them bringing a young crew on top
of yeah we just like split off into two
different shows so like they can have
their own thing and you know if people
want to see young sexy people at Sur
great I would watch it but I'm not young
sexy and it's ER anymore I'm just like
older and
see and at my apartment I was gonna say
you don't like me so hard I guess oh no
I'm still sexy
yes older wiser sex yeah is more which
is if we Hawaiian come in yes when we're
doing a rose a our whole goal is to just
get everyone she's based dangerous wait
isn't the world the world we're making
the world a lot of just a better place
I'm a better drunker place yeah you can
crack open a bottle crack open your book
hmm put Vanderpump rules on ya dream
afternoon I've merged coming out where
my so then it's like I am I'm literally
just gonna take care of your whole life
you say you want to start a cult in the
book okay
that's goals that was actually my
favorite chapter that my publishers
wanted to take out and I fought really
hard for that I'm like this is the cult
of Stassi is like my dream so like
please don't steal this from me yes
[Music]